c'était donc le 4e épisode d'une série
exclusive initiée par notre chaîne LCP
intitulé génération 2008 qui seront-ils
demain 4e épisode d'une série ambitieuse
puisque son réalisateur François Chevret
entend suivre les cinq jeunes que nous
venons de voir chaque année pendant 10
ans histoire au final de mieux capter le
parcours d'une génération bienvenue dans
desbas dog François Chevret vous êtes
journaliste réalisateur et c'est donc à
vous que notre chaîne a a confié la
réalisation de ce formidable projet ce
projet vous l'avez donc entamé voilà 4
ans maintenant hein nos collégiens
faisaient alors leur entrée en classe de
6e et cette fois c'était la rentrée de
Coline Lilou Mael Mohamed et Rywan en 3e
au moment où sonne déjà peut-être hein
pour eux l'heure des premiers choix pour
leur avenir nous allons bien sûr y
revenir ensemble dans un petit instant
Christine canard est également avec nous
aujourd'hui bienvenue vous êtes
psychologue clinicienne docteur en
psychologie de l'enfant enfant et de
l'adolescence et ingénieur de recherche
à lINSERM lINSERM bien sûr l'Institution
nationale de la santé et de la recherche
médical votre dernier livre s'intitule
le développement de l'adolescent
l'adolescent à la recherche de son
identité c'est un livre disponible aux
éditions de bec supérieur et puis enfin
Michel fiz est avec nous bienvenue à
vous Michel fiz très heureux de vous
accueillir sur ce plateau vous êtes
sociologue ancien chercheur au CNRS et
spécialiste des questions de la jeunesse
de l'adolescence et de la famille vous
êtes l'auteur entre autres entre autres
de ce livre j'aide mon adolescent à
grandir c'est un ouvrage publié chez
éérol François Chevret nous retrouvons
donc pour la 4e année ces jeunes que
vous avez suivi depuis la 6e ilsétait
tous issus de ce collège public René des
gailleules euh mais la voilà leur avenir
a fait qu'ils se soi un petit peu
séparés les uns les autres l'une d'entre
elles on l'a vu est parti à Manchester
suiv ses parents Lilou qu'on retrouvera
dans un instant dans un premier extrait
c'est-elle est-elle partie dans un
collège privé euh racontez-nous un petit
peu quelles ont été les les conditions
particulières de de tournage concernant
ce 4e épisode alors l'année de enfin par
an j'ai une quinzaine de journées de
tournage donc l'idée c'est pas d'aller
deux fois par mois par exemple là-bas à
Rennes non l'idée c'est de trouver les
bons moments pour y aller généralement
je laisse un peu passer l'année aussi
pour qu'il y ait une évolution oui euh
mais voilà j'y vais pour des moments
bien précis je passe du temps au
téléphone avec avec chacun des cinq et
on décide ensemble de voilà de de ce
qu'on peut filmer des des séquences qui
vont être intéressantes et euh donc si
on si on divise 15 par 5 il reste 3
jours de tournage pour chacun euh de ces
cinq adolescents il a fallu aussi aller
à Manchester exactement à combien de
reprises j'y suis allé deux fois donc
j'y suis allé au bout de 3 mois c'est en
décembre et ensuite un mois avant que
Colin rentre en France donc voilà pour
voir un peu justement l'évolution voilà
voir au bout de 3 mois comment elle se
sent si déjà ça démarre bien ou pas en
plus c'était pendant l'hiver il faisait
nuit à 17h c'était enfin Plô à
16hchester étant évidemment au nord au
nord de l'Angleterre ouais c'est voilà
et et ensuite j'y suis allé au printemps
c'était voilà il faisait plus beau et
surtout ce qui était intéressant c'était
de faire le bilan de l'année ouais et le
bilan de SK était peut-être une forme de
calvaire elle l' vécu un peu comme
ça Coline à Manchester c'est c'est ce
qu'on a vu dans ce film ça a été une
année difficile pour Coline elle a suivi
ses parents pour un an elle revient à
Rennes hein vous allez la retrouvver à
nouveau mais on sens que ça a été une
période difficile hein pour c'était
difficile je pense que à cet âge- là
séloigné de de ses amis je le dis
d'ailleurs voilà à 800 km de du collège
voilà c'est un peu difficile à vivre euh
elle a un petit frère et une petite sœur
qui sont plus jeunes et qui eux moins
moins difficulté euh mais je pense que à
cet âge- làà particulièrement les
copains sont tellement importants que en
être éloigné ça rend la vie compliquée
d'où l'importance pour elle et pour les
autres des réseaux sociaux mais on en
parlera un peu plus tard à l'occasion de
de cette émission on va retrouver Lilou
pour commencer qui part au collège euh
mais qui n'oublie pas son doudou c'est
le première extrait de votre
film je me maquille parce que genre ça
me
détend dessus
[Musique]
je tou un maquillage qui va avec mes
vêtements bah là j'ai un pull bleu bah
je en maquillage bleu
[Musique]
quoi moi ça m'a l'air
bieni il va
[Musique]
m'attendreci bonne journée bisous bonne
journée alors voilà Lilou elle part au
collège elle se
maquille mais elle oublie pas tout de
même de border son doudou qu'elle va
retrouver le le soir même est-ce que ça
illustre pas peut-être l'entre deux âg
finalement dans lequel se trouvent ces
ces adolescents de 14 ans que l'on voit
dans ce film alors moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ça justement cette
période de transition j'allais dire on
pourrait on pourrait ne pas dire
transition parce qu'il se passe vraiment
plein de choses dans cette période mais
en tant que psychologue du développement
c'est vraiment la transition entre
l'enfance et la et l'âge adulte qui est
très loin d'ailleurs voilà et euh et
Lilou elle elle illustre bien ça parce
que elle a elle a encore un pied dans
l'enfance surtout qu'elle a été un peu
traumatisée par son histoire de
harcèlement quand même on voit qu'elle
qu'elle garde encore des séquelles parce
qu'elle dit je me maquille ça me détend
donc on sent quand même qu'elle qu'elle
a besoin d'être détendue même si elle a
changé d'établissement scolaire quoi
donc c'est ça qui est vraiment vraiment
sympa à voir c'est qu'elle est encore un
pied dans l'enfance et puis un pied dans
cette avancée l'adolescence c'est une
avancée vers l'inconnu quoi et chaque
jour est une inconnue donc elle a besoin
encore de se rassurer et par son
maquillage et par son petit doudou
qu'elle bien qu'elle borde bien Michel
fiz je pense que tout est rajuni
aujourd'hui et à commencé par l'entre
deux âges ouais bon je pense que là
effectivement on a un portrait tout à
fait singulier qui n'est peut-être pas
représentatif encore une fois de la
période d'entrée justement dans
l'adolescence que moi je situe dès la
fin de l'école primaire hein donc le
doudou je l'ai vu personnellement en 6e
encore he entre entre les mains et les
bras des les bras des des petites filles
donc chacun avance à son rythme donc
Lilou évidemment c'est c'est un exemple
en fonction d'un contexte familial d'un
contexte social d'une appréhension de
l'école des difficultés on est malgré
tout dans dans un âge de de transition
pour reprendre la formule que vous avez
utilisé avec ces jeunes je crois pas
beaucoup à l'idée de rupture hein la vie
c'est un continuum donc on avance donc
on recrée jamais rien he pendant
longtemps on a présenté l'adolescence
comme la période d'une création
identitaire comme si avant il y avait
rien mais non l'adolescence c'est quand
même d'abord l'héritier de l'enfant donc
il apporte avec lui un certain bagage
dont le doudou pour pour Lilou par
exemple he voilà mais je pense qu'il y a
une progression il y a une maturation il
y a une ouverture vers le monde il y a
un élargissement des centres d'intérêt
c'est c'est tout ça encore une fois la
progression de vie j'ai trouvé une étude
du ministère de l'Éducation nationale
consacré justement à la tranche d'as qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui euh voilà de
quoi il fait leur vie pour l'essentiel
le sport la musique les jeux vidéos et
bien entendu bien entendu et c'est ce
qui occupe le plus de temps c'est le
travail scolaire qui est fait pour
l'essentiel du temps après les cours
est-ce que ça correspond assez bien à ce
que vous pouvez observer vous chez ces
jeunes de 14 ans aujourd'hui alors je
l'observe d'autant plus que dans mes
dernières études j'ai étudié les
troubles anxieux et dépressifs et s'il y
a bien quelque chose qui rend anxieux
les élèves c'est l'angoisse vis-à-vis de
la réussite scolaire quoi qu'on pense on
a l'impression que il y en a beaucoup
qui s'en foutent c'est pas vrai
finalement et toutes ces pressions qu'on
leur met autour justement bah des de
l'orientation on va le voir et on en
parler par rapport à ce documentaires
aussi par rapport à la réussite scolaire
par rapport aux établissements scolaires
dans lesquels il faut aller tout ça donc
ça c'est vraiment des des choses
effectivement qui du coup leur font
passer du temps sur les devoirs
scolaires ça c'est sûr en je tiens un
personn ge un jeune c'est ran qui lui
est gamer comme on dit adepte des jeux
vidéos et semble-t-il ça l'aide
justement dans la construction à
laquelle vous faisiez référence tout à
l'heure oui oui il utilise les les jeux
vidéos aussi à la fois comme une
occupation mais aussi comme un réseaux
social c'est peut-être peut-être un
sujet que je vais développer à l'avenir
ouis mais oui complètement
c'est chacun a ses propres réseaux
sociaux et en l'occurrence ran lui à
Lecien particulier c'est les jeux vidéo
le sport ça reste important ça l'était
semble-t-il l'année précédente en 4e
pour certains d'entre eux le sport reste
un élément essentielle ça vécu une
certaines valeur aussi le sport après
tout complètement et particulièrement
pour Colin puis que ça a été un peu sa
sa bouée de sauvetage pendant son année
à Manchester c'est qu'elle a réussi à
sociabiliser non pas au collège mais au
volet et elle s'est senti bien à sa
place elle s'est senti elle a fait du
volet des années précédentes à Rennes où
elle se sentait pas trop intégré ouais
et là cette année-là à Manchester elle
était assez mise en valeur et ça lui a
fait beaucoup de bien et elle y allait
trois fois par semaine et c'était
vraiment salvateur pour elle alors là
par contre je ferai une petite nuance
par rapport au résultats de cette
enquête malheureusement il y a en France
un déficit d'activité physique chez les
élèves qui se traduit d'ailleurs par le
fait par la montée de l'obésité qui est
assez impressionnante aujourd'hui et
donc les derniers ministres de
l'éducation ont bien senti qu'il fallait
remettre du sport de l'activité physique
et comme matière je dirais presque
principale hein dans dans l'école hein
l'alliance du corps du corps et de
l'esprit voilà donc là je pense qu'on
est vraiment très très en retard par
rapport à l'Angleterre notamment où on
pratique davantage le sport ou en
Allemagne je pense qu'on a on a on a du
retard à à combler aujourd'hui deuxème
extrait de votre 4e épisode François
chevvret c'est la première journée métro
boulot dodo de Maë et il va se rendre à
ce fameux stage
d'observation qui est un passage
obligatoire aujourd'hui en
3e ce matin Maë file peut-être vers sa
future
vie tu es
stressé non ça va je pense que ça va
être super très
intéressant c'est sa première journée
mtro boulot dodo
attention faut pas que ce soit non plus
euh la seule chose importante dans la
vie le boulot
mais faut que ce soit une passion si tu
travailler juste pour gagner de l'argent
ça n'a aucun intérêt alors travailler
juste pour gagner de l'argent aucun
intérêt pour Maë c'était aussi ce que
pensaient les les quatre autres jeunes
que vous suivez oui même appréhension
par rapport au travail l'idée c'est de
trouver un un travail bon si ça peut
leur apporter de l'argent c'est bien
mais surtout un métier qui les intéresse
qui les qui les amuse ils ont pas envie
de faire du métro boulot dodo juste
voilà sans sans sans y trouver leur
intérêt sans s'y épanouir premier
contact avec les vie professionnelle
c'est le but he de ce stage c'est le but
pédagogique de de de ce stage ça ça
semble important hein c'est ce que vous
nous avez dit tout à l'heure ce premier
contact c'est malheureusement important
parce que c'est la période de transition
dans Cees processus d'orientation qu'on
leur demande qui est beaucoup trop
précoce en 3è en plus quoi donc ça vous
paraît trop précoce ce stage par exemple
pas le stage mais comme c'est toujours
associé à des questions d'orientation et
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire plus tard
euh évidemment que certains ça leur met
la pression ils ont pas je dirais pas
piston mais je dirais réseau quand même
autour de sois voilà euh c'est des
réseaux que que certains n'ont pas donc
ça en privilégie certains et pas
d'autres bon ça c'est Michel F qui en
parlera encore mieux en tant que
sociologue mais euh c'est vrai que c'est
important quand même d' r une angoisse
une charge mentale comme on a l'habitude
de dire aujourd'hui qui qui domine
autour de de de cette question de
l'orientation auprès certains de ces
jeunes ah bah ça met une pression énorme
mais c'est surtout que ça suffit pas
quoi là c'est très bien de faire ça et
je trouve que quand ils ont des stages
où ils peuvent tirer un enseignement de
ces stages j'ai adoré Maë pour ça c'est
qu' il est discret mais il se pose sans
arrer des questions je trouvé très
mature il a été super bien encadré en
plus à West France donc ça ça aide aussi
quoi voilà et mais ça suffit pas parce
que justement il faut aussi quand dans
les processus d'orientation il faut
aussi se demander qui on est quoi qui on
est dans l'instant présent et qui on va
être plus tard ça c'est important aussi
de se dire est-ce que par par rapport à
ce que je connais par rapport au métier
de journaliste par exemple ou
d'informaticien si après pour Mohamed
est-ce que c'est vraiment des valeurs
qui vont me correspondre est-ce que ça
va répondre à cet épanouissement
justement qu'on me demande est-ce que je
seraai capable est-ce que j'auraai
compéten sur ça on s'intéresse trop au à
ce que l'on aime en fait voilà mais ça
suffit pas ça suffit pas c'est il suffit
pas d'aimer un domaine de recherche de
professionnel pour se dire je pourrait
m'orienter vers la vers la vers ça donc
c'est c'est complexe le processus
d'orientation ça commence effectivement
par des par des visites en entreprise
mais ça ça devrait être donné à tous les
élèves d'ailleurs hein et ce thème de
l'orientation d'illeurs on le retrouve
euh à travers le brevet par ailleurs et
puis cette formidable dernière séquence
parce que c'est ce sourire de Mohamed
lorsqu'il apprend qu'il est qu'il est
accepté au lycée châteaubillant à Rennes
qui qui semble le lycée ou ou de tous
les possibles pour Mohamed ce qu'il a
envie c'est d'être avec ses copains
aussi quoi de continuer dans ce dans cet
établissement euh réputé certes mais je
sais pas s'il se projette vraiment sur
ça va me permettre de m'orienter là où
je veux quoi moi ce qui m'a interpellé
aussi c'est Lilou qui justement elle
aussi quand je dis que les séquelles de
du harcèlement ça peut durer longtemps
sur une mise à mal de l'estime de soi
c'est que tout à coup ça a fait
tellement Tach d'huile aussi sur ses
résultats scolaires qu'elle ne veut plus
aller à châteaubillant au contraire elle
veut surtout pas aller à châteaubillant
quoi elle semble vouloir opter elle
plutôt pour une filière technique
technique profession
professionnel qui lui correspondrait
sûrement mais ça ça serait intéressant
de l'interroger encore plus parce qu'on
a l'impression qu'elle s'autocensure
parce que elle dit je n'aime pas l'école
j'ai pas j'ai des difficultés à l'école
alors que ça se trouve c'est juste parce
juste entre guillemets parce que c'est
quand même pas rien parce que elle a des
très mauvais souvenirs d'école à cause
du harcèlement quoi et c'est surtout
qu'elle veut plus subir de pression
c'est ça plus subire de pression elle
dit des mots très forts comme santé
mentale on sent que ça a été travaillé
son harcèlement parce que moi c'est ça
qui m'inquiète en tant que psychologue
quoi cette cette santé mentale là quion
rappelle hein pour ceux qui n'auraient
pas vu l'épisode précédent que
effectivement Lilou a été victime de de
harcèlement scolaire et c'est ce qui a
justifié ce choix de changement
d'établissement pour passer d'un
établissement public à un établissement
privé où où elle est dans dans ce 4e
épisode Michel fil sur cette question de
l'orientation oui alors juste peut-être
pour pour compléter sur la question du
harcèlement je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
faut bien pointer le fait qu'on est dans
une situation de banalisation du
harcèlement j'ai dit un jour peut-être
d'une façon un peu un peu provocquante
mais je crois beaucoup cette for ule que
100 % des élèves sont harcelés l'ont été
ou le seront un jour voilà et ce qui est
très grave c'est qu'on a le sentiment en
écoutant notamment je crois que c'est
colline hein qui a une sorte de fatalité
voilà alors on se débrouille du mieux du
mieux qu'on peut voilà sans dilon
évidemment sur l'atmosphère au sein de
l'école alors s'agissant de de ce de ce
stage je crois que c'est le stage idéal
parce qu'en fin de compte là on a un
stage avec une véritable imprégnation
professionnelle là c'est un un stagiaire
à part entière et je pense que tous les
élèves devraient avoir droit à un stage
de ce type parce qu'il faut aussi
rappeler que c'est dur de trouver un
stage hein en classe en classe de 3e he
donc on est presque un privilégié quand
on a un stage premièrement et deux quand
on a un stage je crois de cette qualité
et la dernière chose par rapport à
l'orientation je partage tout à fait ce
qui ce qui a été dit je crois que
l'orientation devrait être un processus
c'est-à-dire en fin de compte il faut
pas figer ça à un moment donné ça doit
se pour suivre tout le long du lycée de
manière à avoir des désorientations
éventuellement suivie de réorientation
c'est un processus permanent
l'orientation pas un moment figé de
l'histoire scolaire h et néanmoins la
charge mentale que ça exerce sur des
élèves finalement ce ce cette
orientation elle a toujours existé alors
peut-être pas ce stage en entreprise qui
est plus récent lui hein à l'échelle du
temps euh néanmoins l'orientation et la
sélection hein à travers les les notes à
travers le brevet l'obstention ou pas du
brevet on a vu qu'on passait là à un
oral blanc notamment pour certains
d'entre eux bon ça ça a toujours existé
non mais les orientations ont toujours
existé d'ailleurs elles étaient
autrefois beaucoup plus précoces he pour
un certain nombre d'élèves he à 14 ans
on parttit en apprentissage parce qu'on
appartenait malheureusement à un milieu
modeste he ouvrier pour ne pas pour ne
pas le ne pas le nommer moi je pense que
cette association entreprise
administration école devrait être
développp
justement pour permettre d'avoir la
meilleure vue possible des métiers parce
que bon aujourd'hui on ne sait pas quels
seront les métiers dans 20 ans ou dans
30 ans moi ce qui me gêne de plus en
plus c'est qu'alors que l'orientation
scolaire devrait être au sein de l'école
c'est de plus en plus extérieurisé avec
des des coach de toutes sortes avec au
départ c'était le soutien scolaire
maintenant c'est du soutien à
l'orientation et on parle d'orientation
professionnelle alors que c'est dans
hyper longtemps quoi je dire d'abord là
on devrait parler d'orientationol c'est
pour ça qu' limite la seule qui parle de
STMG tout ça d'orientation vraiment
scolaire de formation quoi c'est Lilou
les autres on les projette déjà dans des
métiers ou dans des domaine
professionnel et ça c'est dommage par
c'est pas les parents qui les projettent
aussi oui puis même les les enseignants
parce que on sait on s'est dit et puis
c'est vrai que ça peut être vrai malgré
tout que dès l'instant qu'on se projette
dans un métier ou dans un domaine
professionnel ça va nous motiver à
réussir les études justement mais non
mais je crois que un stage devrait
remplir différentes fonctions la
découverte comme existe des classes de
découvert
euh la mise la mise en poste donc comme
dans le cas de de de de ce garçon donc
une véritable imprégnation euh voilà ça
devrait aussi se démultiplier parce que
les les possibilités professionnelles
sont très très nombreuses aujourd'hui
hein donc faut pas se tromper évidemment
dans le dans le choix et puis François
chevvre il y a il y a un rapport à faire
à la sortie de ce stage et à présenter
aux enseignants hein on l'a vu ça ça
aussi c'est un moment de stress non
bah c'est le c'était leur premier
contact avec un examen donc sur un sujet
qu'il maîtrisaient puisque c un stage
ils avaient ils avaient fait le rapport
de stage écrit mais oui c'était la
première fois et ils ont eu besoin d'une
petite préparation mentale par leurs
profs de fermer les yeux et s'imaginer
tout ça et ouais ça les a stressé ran
particulièrement on peut le voir dans
dans les images oui tout à fait et ça a
éé un moment important ou ouais et sans
doute constructeur aussi sans non mais
je crois qu' est intéressant je sais pas
comment s'est fait le le casting de ces
garçons et filles mais c'est remarqu
parce qu'on a des portraits très
contrastés donc des des des parcours de
vie vraiment très très très singuliers
et tout ça filmé je dirais moi c'est le
sentiment que j'ai eu avec beaucoup de
sobriété et et de pudeur voilà dernier
extrait du de votre film François chev
et de ce 4e épisode évidemment
évidemment l'importance des réseaux
sociaux alors moi j'ai Instagram
Instagram
j'ai snapchat snapchat et TikTok j'en ai
pas et j'en Auris pas de siton donc une
par je sais pas si j'aurais le droit je
sais pas si j'en auraai envie non plus
donc toute façon pour l'instant j'ai pas
de téléphone
donc alors il faut bien peut-être
différencier les choses toutes les
études le confirment ce qui cartonne
chez les jeunes de 14 ans ce sont les
chats hein donc snapchat pour on fait
pas leur publicité mais on va citer
quand même ses applications WhatsApp et
puis les messageries hein tout
simplement pourquoi parce que ça crée
des communautés euh avec ses copains du
sport ses copains du collège sa famille
euh c'est ça qui cartonne chez les
jeunes de 14 ans aujourd'hui et puis il
y a Instagram qui a été cité TikTok
voilà qui sont plus des contenus hein
voilà et qui semblent aujourd'hui moins
utilisés que c'est ces fameux groupes
qui permettent de de créer des
communautés et et et donc de de de
poursuivre la vie sociale au-delà de
l'établissement scolaire aujourd'hui
pour ces jeunes de 14 ans indispensable
les réseaux sociaux sauf pour Mael
visiblement Mael il aucun intérêt ouais
mais euh oui ass c'estz indispensable
Lilou ça a été sa façon de sociabiliser
aussi elle le raconte bien dans le
documentaire euh pour le coup Instagram
elle utilise aussi en messagerie voilà
ce qui servent à peu près tous tous à ça
aussi euh il utilise pour regarder des
contenus des vidéos et cetera ou
effectivement pour échanger entre eux
dans des groupes particuliers et
maintenir comme ça une vie sociale t en
restant chez eux ben chacun a sa façon
de faire après ils sont j'ai j'ai
remarqué qu'il était ils utilisaient
beaucoup les réseaux sociaux pour
communiquer entre eux et pour regarder
des vidéos des photos regarder du
contenu mais finalement il ils se
montrent peu ils produisent peu de
contenu eux-mêmes vraiment dans la
consommation et alors quand à Coline
mais il faut depuis Manchester ça semble
lui avoir sauvé la vie et sauver sa vie
sociale c'était sa seule connexion avec
l'autre côté de la Manche làin
complètement ouais ça lui prend en abusé
d'énerver sa mère au moment de faire ses
devoir ça a été pour elle la booue de
sauvetage on peut dire des choses comme
ça non ah ouioui heureusement que
c'était là ben je oui alors les réseaux
sociaux bah effectivement c'est sa bouée
de sauvetage mais c'est aussi ce qui
l'empêche de s'intégrer quoiou vous
pourrait presque dire ça elle vous
précédez ma question est-ce que c'était
pas effectivement ce qui l'a empêché en
partie peut-être de s'intégrer en partie
parce que c'est évident qu'elle dit au
départ il y a le barrage de la langue
donc ça c'est vrai je me mets bien à sa
place mais finalement au bout d'un an
avec tout ce que fait alors moi je crois
que c'est une famille d'accueil par
contre je pense pas que c'était sa
famille non non c'était c'était ses
parents he ah d'accord ou ok parce que
j'avais l'impression que c ou oui et
voilà avec tout ce qu'elle fait pourtant
pendant les vacances tout ça on
s'aperçoit que qu'elle est presque un
gratte justement par rapport à tout ce
qui est proposé dans sa famille parce
que ce qui compte c'est vraiment la
séparation et et l'angoisse séparation
qu'elle n'a plus justement l'angoisse
par rapport à ses amis qu'elle a laissé
quoi donc c'est un âge façon où ils ont
besoin d'être vraiment affiliés à à
leurs amis rechercher cette amitié
idéaliser cette amitié donc c'est sûr
qu'à la fois c'est une bouée de
sauvetage à la fois ça empêche de
connecter de se connecter avec d'autres
quoi je ve dire c'est évident quoi non
mais la quantité de consommation de
consommation pardon numérique est
aujourd'hui extrêmement importante hein
il est évident que le réseau social
peut-être un enfermement euh ou une
limitation de ses relations à son petit
cercle d'amis déjà existant hein parce
que bon il y a parfois un barrage pour
découvrir d'autres d'autres personnes et
puis le réseau social qui peut-être un
paradis pour certains donc peut-être
pour Lilou d'une certaine manière
peut-être un enfer hein je rappelle
quand même le réseau social c'est
l'outil majeur du harcèlement hein qui
se poursuit après après le temps après
le temps de classe donc voilà donc comme
tout instrument euh novateur le meilleur
et le pire euh sont sont sont là bien
sûr ou le rôle des des parents con
concernant euh ces fameux réseaux
sociaux Maë pour qu'on comprenne bien
c'est parce que lui n'a pas fait cette
démarche d'aller euh s'inscrire sur les
réseaux sociaux qui ne les a pas ou
c'est parce que ses parents n'ont pas
juger
utile de lui donner l'autorisation
parentale nécessaire pour c'est parce
que la la règle dans la famille c'est
qu'il qu'il n'y a pas de téléphone avant
le lycée et lui s est conformé et comme
il le dit il a il a son ordinateur il
regarde Youtube qui est aussi un réseau
social qui peut être utilisé comme un
réseau social euh et voilà et après s'il
s'il y a besoin d'envoyer un message à
un copain pour pour organiser quelque
chose on prend le téléphone d'un parent
et puis ça fonctionne comme ça il
ressend pas plus de besoins que ça on va
rappeler ce que ce que nous dit la loi
tout de même à ce propos hein les
réseaux sociaux sont interdits
aujourd'hui aux enfants de moins de 13
ans en revanche pour les 13 14 ans ça
concerne ce qu'on a vu dans ce film le
consentement des parents est désormais
requis conjointement à celui du mineur
autrement dit la la responsabilité des
des parents est pleinement engagée dans
dans dans cette affaire vous l'
conseillé euh euh vous conseillez aux
parents de d'avoir un œil tout
particulier sur la gestion de ses
réseaux sociaux par leurs enfants
aujourd'hui et comment oui et parfois
c'est mal vécu par les parents ils ont
l'impression d'être
intrusif de de de de de de perdre la
confiance de leurs gamins si jamais ils
vont mettre un œil sur ce qui se passe
sur les réseaux sociaux alors que moi je
dis mais à l'époque où il y avait pas no
téléphone on mettait bien un œil sur les
copains qu'on pouvait avoir les sorties
qu'on pouvait avoir enfin dans la vraie
vie quoi je veux dire donc c'est
incroyable comme aujourd'hui c'est vécu
comme quelque chose d'intrusif alors que
alors que ça me paraît logique d'aller
un peu regarder ce qui se passe un petit
peu alors pas d'aller voilà pas d'aller
demander des détails tout ça mais d'en
parler de mettre en gardeement par
rapport au harcèlement mais aussi au
site porno enfit tout ce qui se passe
sur les sur les réseaux comme discord he
on les a pas non plus nommé mais je veux
dire ça au départ c'est des échanges
puis finalement après ça peut aller très
très loin instagram est le premier
réseau social de du harcèlement dans les
études qui ressortent des études donc
c'est de la comparaison sociale
permanente Dee façon donc
non mais je pense que là les les règles
d'utilisation des réseaux sociaux
doivent être définies en amont en
famille et en concertation voilà ce qui
permet ensuite d'éviter les intrusions
faute de ne pas s'être entendu sur
effectivement le permis le permis et et
et l'interdit hein je crois que les
adolescents d'aujourd'hui sont moi ce
que j'avais appelé un jour des
adolescents numériques hein c'est une
partie de leur vie une grande partie de
leur vie pour certains jour et nuit
d'Ailleurs hein puisque bon la coupure
jour et nuit et aujourd'hui s'efface
s'efface de de beaucoup voilà donc ça
fait partie je crois des des choses des
choses
évidemment qui sont qui sont courantes
mais je crois qu'il y a aussi un grand
effort à faire pour informer les
familles sur comment ça fonctionne tout
ça hein parce que j'ai envie de dire que
les meilleurs parents en sont restés à
des réseaux comme Facebook Twitter pour
prendre deux exemples qui sont B comme
on aurait dit autrefis il y a plus il y
a plus ad le sang normal qui est
aujourd'hui sur un réseau comme comme
comme facebook 14 ans c'est c'est malgré
tout c'est un âge où on se construit
contre contre ses parents contre voilà
le le père la mère en tout cas c'est
très proche cellule familial les réseaux
sociaux c'est un terrain d'affrontement
aujourd'hui entre entre ces adolescents
et leurs parents très clairement c'est
il y a un bras de fer sur ce sujet on se
construit contre ses parents euh moi ce
que j'ai vu c'est qu'il y avait il m'ont
expliqué qu'il y avait eu des
discussions entre eux ouis donc ça
rejoint ce qu'a dit Michel F ouais voilà
et voilà après des dépressions
régulières allez je peux avoir un
téléphone je peux avoir les réseaux
sociaux oui oui c'est pas qu'on se
construit contre ses parents en fait
c'est parce que c'est complètement in
incontournable moi ce que je dis aux
adolescents et même aux adultes de toute
façon tout est fait pour qu'ils y
restent donc c'est pas une question de
confiance à avoir avec les le dialogue
ne suffit même plus les parents sont
complètement dépassés quand même he
c'est pas parce qu'ils connaissent pas
les comment ça marche il y a pas même
pas besoin de savoir comment ça marche
c'est plus cette relation complexe aux
écrans et comme tout est fait pour
qu'ils y reste on a besoin de d'avoir un
contrôle parental quand même ou un autre
contrôle mais un contrôle parental ça
c'est sûr surtout encore à 14 à 14 ans
quoi pour apprendre à réguler l'usage de
ses écrans justement alors ce qu'on a
pas trouvé dans ce 4e épisode c'est
voilà peut-être première relation
amoureuse on n pas bien vu dans dans ce
4e épisode ce qui est voilà le leur vie
on a un début de vie festive des débuts
de vie amoureuse vous n'avez pas
souhaité les mettre dans cet épisode
elle n'existe pas encore chez jeunes ou
si peu qu'elle méritait pas d'y être euh
elles existent mais ils tiennent à leur
vie privée ils ont vraiment pas envie
d'en parler à la caméra donc voilà j'ai
tenté et clairement c'était un stop
voilà même sur le comment chacun voyait
les garçons comment il voyaent les fill
inversement on m'a mis un stop direct
voilà chacun m'a mis son stop donc j'ai
pas insisté et voilà le voilà ces
documentaires là on les construit
ensemble aussi et moi j'attends
j'attends leur validation pour pouvoir
en parler et quand ils seront prêt on le
fera mais par aussi un âge où commence
oui et là je pense qu'il faut rappeler
un peu comment les choses se passent
depuis depuis l'école primaire hein on
est d'abord dans la confusion des sexes
on est ensemble fille et garçon même
s'il y a des moments séparés et puis on
arrive à la séparation hein parce
qu'effectivement on doit se construire
en tant que être masculin ou être
féminin he et puis dernière étape on se
remet dans la confusion et donc c'est le
temps des relations amoureuses pour
lequel effectivement on on comprend
qu'il puisse y avoir beaucoup de pudeur
notamment face à la caméra et en famille
aujourd'hui donc là attention aux
parents pas d'intrusion hein la vie
privée c'est la vie privée hein y
compris pour des des garçons et filles
de 14 ans B ce sera le mot de la fin
vraiment un grand merci hein à tous les
trois évidemment spécialement à vous
hein François chevvret puisque on attend
maintenant avec impatience l'épisode euh
5 le 5e épisode c'est la rentrée au
lycée vous avez commencé le tournage
seconde oui j'ai filmé la rentrée ça y
est ouais bon on a hâte de vous
retrouver en tout cas l'année prochaine
hein pour voir où en seront nos cinq
adolescents avec cette rentrée donc en
seconde hein ça sera le le le 5èe
épisode euh merci beaucoup aussi à Alice
de de branon Sarah eudelier qui m'ont
toutes deux aidé à préparer cette
émission aujourd'hui vos réactions à ce
qui a été dit sur ce plateau ça sera sur
hashtag desbadoc et oui Michel F les r
sociaux et puis vous pourrez même réagir
à ce que seront ces réactions si vous le
souhaitez et puis on se retrouve très
bientôt bien sûr pour un nouveau débat
doc et ça sera bien entendu avec son
documentaire et son débat à
[Musique]
bientôt